Dune is a huge gigantic sadness in my
life that's my one in my mind big
failure but I learned a tremendous
amount on that film Dune took 3 years to
make start to finish but it was a
nightmare it was a slow dying the death
and a terrible experience and the reason
is I didn't have Final Cut I had such a
great time in in Mexico City the
greatest crew cast it was beautiful but
when you don't have Final Cut and I knew
this already but why did I do it I don't
know I trusted that it would work out
but um it was very naive and the wrong
move the film is not the film that I
would have made had I had that final
control so that's the big lesson don't
make a film if it can't be the film you
want to make it's a joke and and a sick
joke and it'll kill you